มีสาร
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน 5 ผู้หญิง
สบายดีนะคะสบายดีค่ะครูเอ๋สบายดีนะคะสบาย
ดีค่ะผู้หญิงอ่ะกูโอเคมั้ยโอเค
โอเค
เดี๋ยวกูเองเขาแชร์สกรีนนะคะได้ค่ะอ้าว
ครูหญิงคะวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะวันอังคาร
[เพลง]
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 ค่ะวันที่ 24 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
เมื่อเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะตีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ค่ะ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ
022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา 4
โมง 8 นาทีค่ะ 4 โมงเย็นเนาะใช่ 16:00 น 8
นาทีเย้
ทำไมเย้
เย็นแล้วไม่ร้อนแล้วก็
ผู้หญิงรู้สึกภาพไปโยกโยกไหมเหนื่อยค่ะ
ไม่ๆๆโอเคโอเคเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนที่นั่ง
คือนักเรียนค้าที่บ้านครูเอ๋เนี่ยมีห้อง
ค่ะก็จะมีห้องครัวแล้วก็ห้องอาบธรรมดาคู๋
นั่งที่นี่ที่ห้องนะคะจะมีโต๊ะค่ะมิดมีตก
นี้
โต๊ะ
ละคอมพิวเตอร์อยู่ที่โต๊ะแต่วันนี้นะที่
ห้องมีเสียงอื่นอ่า
คู่เอกก็เปลี่ยนมาห้องข้างนอกที่โซฟาขอ
ที่โซฟาห้องตรงนี้เนี่ยไม่มีเสียงไม่มี
โต๊ะด้วย
ไม่มีเสียงอื่น
ไม่มีโต๊ะมีโซฟาตอนนี้อยู่คอมพิวเตอร์ที่
โซฟาก็เลยจะโยกสอนแต่จริงไม่โยกค่ะโอเค
โอเคนะคะทราย
โอเคมั้ยโอเคทีนี้วันนี้มาคุยลบก่อนที่ 3
ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋ - วันที่ลบเวลา
ตายอะเดี๋ยวกูเอ๋จะว่ารูปเวทขอสีเทา
คุยว่าอะไรคุณหรือว่ารูปอะไรอ่ะผู้หญิง
คิดคิดอะไรๆมีกิจ
เหมา
ไม่ใช่อ่ะ
อะไรจะยาวๆอีปิด้วย
อะไม่สองปีกไม่คิดว่าครีบแล้วค่ะไม่ค่ะ
เขารู้แล้วเครื่องบิน
เครื่องบินอันนี้หรืออย่างเงี้ยโอเคอ่ะ
เออ
เครื่องบิน
ชายเครื่องบินอะมีหน้าต่างด้วยอะไรคะครู
เอ๋ว่าเครื่องบินทำไมอ๋อครูเอ๋เนี่ยจะถ้า
ถามครูหญิงว่าผู้หญิงนั่งเครื่องบินนะคะ
นั่งค่ะบิน
ผู้หญิงนั่งข้างในแล้วครูเอ๋ออกหน้าทั้ง
ในเครื่องบินขอโทษค่ะขอโทษหากผู้หญิงนะคะ
นั่งอ่าสีดำและกันนั่งข้างในนะคะ
อาหารนั่งข้างในเครื่องบินผู้หญิงนั่ง
ข้างในเครื่องบินน่ะครั้งแรกครั้งหลังตอน
อายุเท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิงนั่งเครื่องบิน
ครั้งแรกตอนอายุ
30 ปีค่ะครูเอ๋
30 ปี
ซ้าย
ผู้หญิงนั่งเครื่องบินไปไหนคะผู้หญิงนั่ง
เครื่องบินไปประเทศอังกฤษค่ะครูนี่
อย่าไปไกลไกลไกลมา
แล้วแล้วครูเอ๋ล่ะคะครูเอ๋เอ๋นั่งเครื่อง
บินครั้งแรกตอนอายุเท่าไหร่ตอนอายุ 20 ปี
ค่ะมีงู
ประมาณประมาณ
ถ้วยเอ๋นั่งไปไหน
นั่งไปกรุงเทพฯฮะ
อ้าวแล้วครูเอ๋นั่งจากไหนจ๊ะภูเก็ตค่ะค่ะ
อันนี้ประเทศไทยค่ะ
แล้วก็ตรงนี้
ตรงนี้ตรงนี้อันนี้ภูเก็ตนะคะแล้วตอนนี้
กรุงเทพฯ
ครูเอ๋นั่งเครื่องบินจาก
เกาะภูเก็ตมา
กรุงเทพฯ
บ้านครูเอ๋อยู่ภูเก็ตหรอคะไม่ใช่
แบนครูเอ๋อยู่
ชลบุรีอ้าวตรงนี้บ้านครูเอกชลบุรีแต่ครู
เอ๋มาอยู่
กรุงเทพฯจะมาจากชลบุรีก็มา
กรุงเทพฯเราก็กรุงเทพฯกูอีกก็ไปภูเก็ต
แล้วก็แล้วนั่งเครื่องบิน
กลับ
กรุงเทพฯเอาแล้วจากกรุงเทพไปภูเก็ตครูเอ๋
ไม่ได้นั่งเครื่องบิน
นั่งรถบัสค่ะ
ครูเอ๋คะผู้หญิงถามได้ไหมคะอะไรคะหน้า
เว็บบัสจากกรุงเทพฯไปภูเก็ตกี่ชั่วโมง
โอ๊ะๆ
ประมาณ 11 ชั่วโมงความผู้หญิงเมื่อก่อนกู
เอมไปทำงานออก
ผู้หญิงคิดครูเอ๋ไปภูเก็ตไปเที่ยวไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่ครูเอ๋อยู่ที่รถบัสแล้วครูเอกก็
เป็นคนไทยแล้วก็มีคนไทยคนไทยคนไทยกูเอกก็
สวัสดีค่ะที่นี้ภูเก็ตค่ะภูเก็ตสวยอ่า
แล้วก็สวัสดีค่ะไปเรือค่ะ
โอเคทำงานบนเรือเหรอคะคู๋ทำงานที่เรือนี้
เลยค่ะ
อันดามันปริ๊นเซสสเพลงอ่านภาษาไทย
มาฝากสะไภ้อันนี้อันดามันปริ๊นเซสเอกทำ
งานที่นี่ที่เรืออันดำมาโอเคเข้าใจภูเก็ต
มีทะเลทรายและก็นั่งรถรถบัสจาก
กรุงเทพฯนะคะอะสีสีอะไรดีสีชมพูดีกว่า
กรุงเทพน่ะไปภูเก็ตธรรมดาแล้วก็ลง
เรือสีน้ำเงินแล้วกัน
ขอ
แล้วก็ลงเรือเสร็จแล้วก็ขึ้นจากเรือนั่ง
รถบัสกับ
กรุงเทพฯอ้าว
แต่ครูบอกครูลีนั่งเครื่องบินกลับ
กรุงเทพฯเพราะว่า
ทำไมอ่ะมีอยู่ 1 ครั้งนี่ๆจะคุยอีกจะมี
รูปให้ดู
ค่ารถบัสต้องขึ้นไปดูวิวที่นี่ค่ะตรงนี้
เป็นวิวที่ไหนคะครูอันนี้ที่ภูเก็ตใช่ไหม
คะชื่ออะไรครับตรงนี้ที่แหลมพรหมเทพอส.
เอ่อ
ออออออออม.ร.ว.ด้านเนี้ยลงไปแล้วก็ลงไป
ทะเล
พอดีทะเลอันนี้ทะเลหาอันสูงแล้วก็ลงมาลง
แล้วก็ราไวย์ค่ะอ๋อ
คู๋นะอยู่ที่รถบัสนั่นแหละกูหญิงแล้วก็
ปรากฏว่ารถบัสเนี่ยอยู่ที่นี่
แล้วเลี้ยวที่นี่น่ะครูเอ๋อยู่ยืนอยู่ที่
ที่ใกล้ๆประตูที่รถบัสบาร์ตูร์อ๋อตรงนี้
มีประตูแล้วครูเอ๋ยืนอยู่ตรงนี้แล้วประตู
เนี่ยเปิดหรือปิดคะประตูรถบัสประตูปิดแต่
ไม่ล็อคพอรถมาเลี้ยงป๋าครูเอกก็ซึ่งเราก็
เป็น Superman  Way ตกเหรอคะไม่ใช่ประตู
ตรงนี้ค่ะประตูมันเปิด
แล้วครูเอกก็อยู่ตรงนี้
แล้วครูเอกก่อนตกรถขับผู้หญิง
ผู้เห็นเป็นยังไงคะเป็นต่อตกแล้วคุย
กับ
สลบเลยเหรอคะตลกค่ะสลบหน้ามีคนขอบคุณครู
เอ๋ไปโรงพยาบาลหนักหนาขึ้นคู๋ตกแล้วพระ
เอกก็ไม่รู้แล้วใช่ไหมไม่รู้อะไรแล้วอ้าว
รู้นิดหน่อย
ก็เอาครูเอ๋ไปโรงพยาบาลนะคะ
โรงพยาบาลที่โรงพยาบาลก็มีคุณหมอค่ะคุณ
หมอผู้หญิง
หนูมี
อาหมอเหรอคุณหมอก็ที่หัวกูเอกตรงนี้กู
หญิงของครูเอ๋เนี่ยก่อนครูเอ๋ตบหัวเนี่ย
แกล้งแพ่งก้อนหิน
คู๋หัวคุณแข็งมากนะคะคุณไม่โอคุณโอเค
เนี่ยไม่โอเคกูหญิงอยู่ที่นี่เห็นป่ะอ๋อ
อุ๊ยๆมีแผลเป็นหรอคะใช่ที่นี่แตก
แล้วก็คุณหมอเย็บอยากตรงนี้ค่ะเดี๋ยวคุณ
หมอก็เย็บเย็บไอ้คิวบ๊ายบายเลยกูหญิง
เมื่อก่อนมีไอคิวมากๆเมื่อก่อนจมูกโด่ง
มากโกหกค่ะตัวเอง
ก็กระแทก
จมูกไป by
Gu  a ต้องกระแทกแล้วก็จมูกโด่งค่ะไปใส่
ซิลิโคนอิอิ
ขอโทษของไว้หัวหัวหน้าผากกระแทกแล้วก็แตก
นี่
แตกก็เลยอ้ะปวดหัวใช่ไหมโอ้โหก็ปวดหัวมาก
ๆนะ
r-top ฟิตครูเอกก็เลยบอกว่าเอ๋
เอกกลัวกลัวรถบัสผู้หญิงอ๋ออ๋อใช่พวกกู
เอกจะกลับกรุงเทพฯต้องนั่งรถบัสนี่ใช่ไหม
คะ
สุขสันต์
ที่ออฟฟิศก็เลยบอกโอเคตอนนี้หัวเนี่ย
กระแทกไม่รู้ข้างในอะไรเป็นยังไงก็เลยให้
นั่งเครื่องบินจะเอาลำ
กรุงเทพฯ
through  a ก็เป็นครั้งแรกใช่ไหมคะใช่
แล้วหญิงหรือไม่ ami แฟชั่นยังไงเดี๋ยวมี
แฟชั่นยังไงนั่งเครื่องบินครั้งแรกเป๊ะ
ต้องแบบนี้ผมใหญ่
เอกว่าคุยว่าแต่อันดีกว่าอ้ะ
love นี่เลยค่ะ
ทำไมต้องมีผมใหญ่ๆเอาก็นั่งเครื่องบินไง
เครื่องบินเดี๋ยวหู
แผงนี่เลยค่ะกูเองกูเอกเป็นแบบนี้
เกรย์ต้องแต่งใส่เสื้อสวยๆแน่ๆเลย
เอาเขตขัดเปียหรอคะถักเปียสองข้าง
ไฟล์อ่าแล้วก็ครูเอ๋ที่นี่ใช่ไหม 4 แสน
บาท 4 หัวหัวเเตกหัวแต่
เงินน้อย
ไม่ยิ้มไม่อินเพราะว่ามีที่นี่มีมีมีสี
ม่วงที่นี่
2 มีพี่
เหมือนโดนต่อย
ไม่มีไหวเลยคือตรงนี้หัวแตกตรงนี้สีม่วง
ตาก็ปิดๆอ่าเพราะว่าตกรถใช่มั้ยหัวเนี่ย
กระแทกนอนโรงพยาบาล 1 วันค่ะแล้วก็ต้อง
ใส่ใส่แว่นไปแว่น
ใส่แว่นตา
ใส่แว่นตาสีดำหรอแว่นตาดำใช่ใส่แว่นขา
R ใส่แว่นตาใหญ่มากๆมีทั้งหมดตรงนี้ขอ
ปิด of ผมข้างหน้าเป็นแบบนี้เลยที่จริง
ผมที่นี่
มีผมม้าใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋ชาย
ผมเกาะติดปิดปิดแผลอ่า
นะคะแล้วก็อ้ะแฟชั่นเสื้อเสื้ออะไรใส่
เสื้ออะไรนั่งเครื่องบินครั้งแรกเลยนะ
เขาเรียกเสื้อฮาวายอ่ะ
เสื้อที่มีลายดอกไม้ใช่ไหมครับพี่เอ๋ดอก
ไม้ดอกไม้
แล้วก็กางเกง
ขาสั้น
กูอ่ะ
อะไรคะผู้หญิงเลิกผู้หญิงคิดว่าครูเอ๋แบบ
ome แฟชั่นสวยๆนั่งเครื่องบินครั้งแรกไง
ก็นึกคู๋วาดอะไรเนี่ย
กูเอกจะขยับได้ไหมอะเนี้ย
อ้ะขึ้นไปข้างบนก่อน
อันนี้ดีมากขยับได้นะคะ
ขยายได้ด้วย
แล้วกางเกงขึ้นไปด้วยค่ะอ่ะอ่านี่แฟชั่น
คู๋ผู้หญิงเราก็
ตัดขานะคะค่ะ
รองเท้าเดินทะเล
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ก็ไม่ใช่รองเท้า
สูงๆไม่ใช่รองเท้าคัทชูแบบนี้
ไม่ใช่รองเท้าทะเลแล้วก็อ่ะ
มือหนึ่งหมื่นค่ะเป็นยังไงคะคือหรือ
อะไรเค้าคือเองอาหมู
เป็นตุ๊กตาของครูเอ๋เหรอคะอ๋อตอนครูเอ๋
อยู่โรงพยาบาลกูโอ้ยเจ็บ
ต้องมีคนใจดีซื้อตุ๊กตา
ให้ครูเอ๋กอดเพื่อนกัน
เพื่อนนั้นเอ๋ไม่เจ็บนะ
ส่วนมื้อนี้มื้อนี้ก็มีอะไรไหมคะมีผ้าพัน
อยู่อ๋อ
[เพลง]
มันเจ็บใช่มั้ยก็มีผ้าพันห่า
วแฟชั่นครูเอ๋คะนักเรียนขึ้นเครื่องบินไอ
คิวไม่มีโอปวดหัวแล้ว
มีแป้งเครื่องบินคู๋เดินเดินคนเดียวนะคะ
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้คนอื่นแต่คู่เอ๋เจนนะไม่
สบายไม่มีกูอีกแล้วก็มีอีกหนึ่งคนด้วยกัน
หรอคะไม่มีหนึ่งคนไปส่งแล้วก็มึงรถพระเอก
ก็เครื่องบินแล้วก็กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมอ่ะไรวะ
ตัวเองก็ปวดหัวแล้วก็ขึ้นแล้วคุยก็โห
อะไรคะ
ฝรั่งฝรั่งฝรั่งฝรั่งอเมริกาแคนาดายุโรป
คนไทยที่ไหนเออมีคนไทยไหมบนเครื่องบิน
โอ้ว
อาทิตย์นั้นที่คุยอีกขึ้นใช่ไหมคะเที่ยว
น่ะเที่ยวนั้นไม่มีคนไทยมีแอร์โฮสเตสคน
ไทย doc รู๋คนไทยอ่ะ L เสร็จก็พูดเอา We
Are อันนี้เสื้อชูชีพนะรักอะอันนี้เข็ม
ขัดนะน่ะเข็มขัดต่อต้องล็อคเข็มขัดได้คู่
เอกก็ฟังไม่เข้าใจปวดหัวหรือเอกก็นั่ง
แล้วก็แอร์ข้อเสียก็บอกล็อคเข็มขัด
เครื่องบินกำลังจะขึ้นค่ะก็นั่งใช่ไหม
แล้วกูอ่ะๆลืมบอกก่อนเครื่องบินจะขึ้นกู
อีกกับผู้คิดนะทำอะไรคะถุ้ยทำอะไรอ่ะที่
นั่งมันเป็นอย่างนี้ใช่ไหม 1
3 ค่ะตอนนี้ทางเดิน
ครูเอ๋นั่งตรงนี้อ๋อพี่เอ๋นั่งติดทางเดิน
แล้วก็จะมีฝรั่งทางนี้ว่างเอาไว้คิดคนไทย
คนไทยคนอาเภอเปิดรอใช่ไหมรออีกหนึ่งคนก็
ได้ปรากฏว่าคนที่มาเดินป่องๆเป็นฝรั่งขอ
ก็ไม่ใช่คนไทยเป็นผู้ชายผมยาวๆ
ผู้ชายก่อนขอโทษแล้วก็ข้ามไปเลยกูเห็น
นั่งที่นี่ข้ามกูเอกไม่ต้องลุกแล้วก็เดิน
ออกใช่ไหมไม่ต้องรู้ข้าวแล้วเขาก็นั่ง
แล้วก็ฮัลโหลโหล How  are  you เออก็พูด
พูดๆคุยกัน
เป็นยังไงพี่คุยกับเขาไหม
Yes  Yes  Yes อย่างเดียวภาวะกด Yes
สบายดีไหมเยสอย่า
อ่าเจ็บใช่ไหม Yes เจอ
Yes  No ฮะโอเค Thank  You ไม่ 3 คำ
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยกูเอกโอ้โอ้โอ้เขาพูดเยอะๆ
กูไอ้ฟังไม่เข้าใจหัวกูเอกก็เลยหลับค่ะ
หลับตาแล้วแอร์โฮสเตสก็พูดใช่ไหมโอเคมี
ล็อคเข็มขัดนะถ้าเอกล็อคเข็มขัดก็ลืมตา
ใช่มั้ยอ้ะ
คุณคุณฝรั่งคนเนี้ยเขาก็อยู่ๆอะไรนะ save
เบลล์
ล็อคเข็มขัดกูอีกอยู่ที่ไหนวะ
พี่เอหาเบื่อเหมือนรถเหรอคะเธอจะอยู่ที่
นี่แล้วก็ใช่กูเอกก็โอ้วแอร์โฮสเตสไม่มี
เข็มขัดที่นี่
ที่แล้วไม่มีเข็มขัดจะแออเปิดเฟสทำยังไง
แอร์โฮสเตสอยู่ไกลไม่เห็นครูเอ๋แล้วกูเอง
ทำยังไงอ่ะครูเอ๋หาเข็มขัดไม่เจอ
ฝรั่งคนนี้บอกว่าครูเอ๋
นั่งทับเข็มขัด
ก็เห็นนั่งเข็มขัดอยู่ที่นี่ก็เห็นนั่ง
กูเห็นนั่งทับอย่างนี้อ่ะ
เขาใจดีมากเขาก็ดึงขึ้นมาให้กูเอ๋
[เพลง]
จะถูกได้ไหม
แล้วทำยังไงอ่ะเหมือนแล้วเนี่ยแล้วก็ถูก
โอเคมั๊ยค่ะไม่ได้ผูกไม่ได้ต้องล๊อกขา
ล็อคเข้าไปด้วยกัน IQ ไม่มีต้องแล้วพี่
เอ๋ทำยังไงอ่ะก็ผู้ชายคนนี้ก็จับล็อคให้
หนูใจดีเนาะใช่แล้วเครื่องบินก็โอเคมีน้ำ
เสิร์ฟมีอะไรนะ snack เสิร์ฟแล้วก็ไปค่ะ
[เพลง]
สนามบินดอนเมืองค่ะเครื่องบินกำลังจะลง
หรอลงลงลง
จริงๆก่อนก่อนลง
เครื่องบินขึ้นขึ้นผู้ชายคนนี้ก็นอนหลับ
ค่ะคูเอกอ้ะ
ปวดฉี่ต่อบอร์ดดื่มน้ำใช่ไหมดื่มน้ำก็แบบ
ๆๆดีแล้วครูเอ๋เอาเข็มขัดออกได้ไหมคะถ้า
รถอ่ะมันก็กดใช่ไหม
กดก็ออกหึเล็กดีน่ะต้องง้าง
ใช่ไหมหางาแต่ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ตอนยกตัวเอกไม่
สบายแล้วก็นั่งเครื่องบินครั้งแรกด้วยไง
แบบได้ไม่เข้าใจ
ออกยังไงออกเดี๋ยว
กูเองไปเข็มขัดไม่ได้นะคะกูออกจากเข็มขัด
ไม่ได้ผู้หญิง
กลัวจะ
เข็มขัดล็อคกูเองอ่ะกูเอกก็พยายามลงมา
ข้างล่างก็ไม่ได้ออกทางนี้ก็ไม่ได้ห้องกด
กดก็ไม่มีทำไม่ได้กูอีกแล้ว
เกรดทำยังไงขอให้อดทนค่ะ
เรื่องดอนเมืองดอนเมืองดอนเมือง 4 เอกก็
แอร์โฮสเตส air  hostess ไม่เห็นใช่ป่ะกู
เองอะอดทนจน
ดอนเมืองค่ะเครื่องบินลงลงๆแล้วก็จอด
ทุกคนก็ลุกแล้วก็ไปไปอ่าฝรั่งคนนี้ก็ไปคน
ที่จะไปกูอีกอ่ะคู๋มีเข็มขัดล็อคอยู่
ออสเตรพูดเบาๆค่ะ
และนี่ไม่ได้ยินก็เดินเดินเดินเดินไปแล้ว
ก็ไปที่ประตูค่ะขึ้นบินมีประตูออกกำลัง
อยู่ที่นี่ก็สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีชอบคุณค่ะค่ะ
ขอบคุณค่ะค่ะขอบคุณค่ะแอร์โฮสเตสเอกออก
ยังไงคุยก็นั่งเราก็จะคุยเดี๋ยวมาภูเก็ต
อีกครั้งนึง
ของกลุ่มรถบัส
จอดเสร็จแล้วเดี๋ยว
เครื่องบินภูเก็ตกรุงเทพออกไม่ได้ก็
กรุงเทพภูเก็ตควรเขตกรุงเทพฯก็ปวดฉี่
กูเอกกันนั่งนั่งแล้วก็ได้ยินเสียงมึงมึง
ซึ่งซึ่งเสียงคนเดินเหรอแอร์โฮสเตสทำไม
เดินดังๆกูอีกหันไปดูอุ้ยอะไรคะมิสเปิดคน
นี้อ๋อมิสเตอร์ฝรั่งผมยาวๆนะก็ยืนอยู่ที่
นี่ค่ะ
แล้วก็มิสเตอร์ฝรั่งก็โอ้อะไรนะเรียกคุย
ว่าเด็กๆอ๋อโอคิดเหรอคะ R เพราะอะไรนะโอ้
คิด I  got  you  are
โป้ฝรั่งคิดได้ครูเอ๋น่ะล็อคเข็มขัดไม่
เป็นฟังจะเดินเดินไปแล้วก็หันมาอ้อไม่มี
เอ๋ฝรั่งก็คิดขายไปไหนฝรั่งก็เดินเดินมา
เอกก็อยู่ที่นี่ฝรั่งก็คิดออเปิดเข็มขัด
ไม่ได้
เอกก็บอกหน้าฝรั่งฝรั่งก่อนเปิดเข็มขัด
ให้เออ
ปลดล็อคปลดล็อคให้แล้วก็จูงมือแล้วก็พูด
your พาเล่นไม่ดีนะทำไมเด็กๆเครื่องบิน
คนเดียวคอมเพลง
จริงๆกูอีก 20 ปีแล้วผู้หญิงเออแต่ว่า
ฝรั่งอาจจะเห็นแบบตัวเล็กๆไสวหน้าเด็กๆก็
เลยคิดอาจาร์ยอุ๊ซัก 14  45 มั้ยใช่ฝรั่ง
กิน 14-15 ปีเหรอ
นะครับถึงดอนเมืองใช่ไหมคะก็มีค่ะพี่
มารับฝรั่งก็เดินมาแล้วก็คอมเพล
ทำไมให้นั่งเครื่องบินคนเดียวทำไมให้เด็ก
ๆนั่งเครื่องบินคนเดียวออกฝรั่งคอมเพลน
เออเป็นพ่อไม่ดีนะคะทำไมอันนี้เด็กๆไม่
รู้จักเครื่องบินก็พูดพูดพูดโกรธมาก
senior  senior ของครูเอ๋เป็นรุ่นพี่คน
ไทยบอกรุ่นหน่อยพี่รุ่นพี่ก็ตกใจตอนนั้น
ก็นั่งพูดอะไรเอ๋
ก็บอกไม่เข้าใจ
ฝรั่งใจดี
เฮ้อโอเคนะล็อกที่เครื่องบินออกไม่ได้
สายถ้าฝรั่งไม่กลับมาคุยก็ต้องรอรอพี่ก็
ต้องกลับภูเก็ตแล้วก็มาใหม่แล้วก็ภูเก็ต
แล้วก็กรุงเทพฯไม่เออเดี๋ยวหาหมอเสร็จมา
แล้วก็เช็คอ๋อ
คือกูดีกู a นะที่นี่เจ็บแล้วก็ปวดหัวไม่
ด่าปังแอร์โฮสเตสพูดอะไรราคาทรายทราบว่า
เหตุไม่สบายด้วยไงตอนนั้นแล้วก็เครื่อง
บินครั้งที่ 1 ก็ไม่เข้าใจนะคะตายค่ะโอเค
สนุกค่ะขอบพระหนุกคะมิสเตอร์ซ้ายมิสเตอร์
อะไรไม่รู้ไม่รู้
ถ้าครูเอ๋ไม่มีครั้งแรกก็จะไม่เข้าใจไง
ทุกคนเวลานั่งเครื่องบินครั้งแรกคิดว่า
ไม่เข้าใจเหมือนกันใส่ยังไงแล้วเมื่อก่อน
ไม่มี YouTube ใช่ไหมไม่มีคอมพิวเตอร์
ด้วยก็ไม่มีดูใน YouTube ไม่ได้ใช่แล้วก็
ไม่มีแบบทีวีให้ดูใช่ไหมใช่มั้ยโจทย์ใน
ที่นั่งอ่ะ
ก็ต้องดู a-host เดชอ่ะใต้อนึ่งนักเรียน
ชั้นหนึ่งประมาณ 1989 เนาะ
191  989 บาทประมาณ
398 ประมาณ 8  8  9 ประมาณนั้นน่ะ
990 ประมาณเนี้ย
1990 ประมาณเนี้ยอ่ะค่ะอาหารนี่แหละกู
หิวไม่รู้รึตายนะเพราะว่าครูอันนี้คือครู
เอ๋นั่งเครื่องบินครั้งแรกแล้วก็นั่ง
ครั้งแรกก็แบบปวดหัวด้วยนะ
ออกเป็นครั้งแรกนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียนชาย
หัวเราะคู๋มากๆใช่ไหมนักเรียนขอบคุณคุณ
ไม่รู้ใครนะคะมิสเตอร์ผมยาวนะผมยาวมีขน
เยอะๆนะคะจี้
อีกด้วยล็อคเข็มขัดให้ครูเอ๋แล้วก็ปลด
ล็อคเข็มขัดให้ครูเอ๋ด้วยพาผู้ a ไปส่ง
ให้คนไทย
ดีว่าขอบคุณค่ะทรายค่ะนี่หมดเวลาแล้วใช่
ไหมคะใช่ค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็ถ้านักเรียนนั่ง
เครื่องบินครั้งแรกแล้วเหมือนครูเอ๋เอ๋ก็
คอมเม้นต์ได้นะคะนักเรียนโอ้ครูเอ๋เหมือน
กัน
โอเคค่ะงั้นคลิปนี้ตัวเอกกับผู้หญิงไป
ก่อนนะคะค่ะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะถ้ามี